من بيروت ينضم الينا العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي سياده العميد
الروسي يقولون انهم سيستهدفون اي سفينه
اوكرانيه
والاوكرانيون يردون بالمثل لانهم
سيعتبرونها سفينه حربيه الى اي مدى هذا
التهديد تعتقد انه قابل للتنفيذ وماذا
يمكن ان تكون اثاره
عثمان مساحه اوكرانيا 600 الف كيلو متر
مربع مساحه البحر الاسود تقريبا بالاربع
مئه الف كيلو متر مربع اليوم لدينا مسرح
جديد وكانه اصبح مليون كيلومتر مربع اليوم
البحريه الاوكرانيه ليست موجوده البحريه
الروسيه موجوده لكنها بعيده عن الشواطئ
الاوكرانيه البارحه
وهو مساعد وزير الخارجيه قال لن نضرب
السفن الحربيه سنصعد عليها للتفتيش يعني
بدانا نرى تراجع من حده الصراع وكانه
المرحله القادمه هي شيء عسكري لاهداف
سياسيه جيو سياسيه كاعاده
التفاوض على الاتفاق بحد ذاته لانه قانونا
لا تزال لا يزال الاتفاق موجود الامم
المتحده تركيا موجوده فاذا انت في مرحله
جديده هي مرحله التفاوض مرحله اوكرانيا
اليوم اوكرانيا لديها الوسائل جربتها على
الكرش على موسكوبا وعلى غيرها لكن على
البحر الاسود هل يمكنها فعلا ان تدخل في
مواجهه مع القوات البحريه الروسيه ما الذي
يمكن ان يجره عليها هذا التصعيد
مريم ليس بحريه او بارجه ضد بارجه او
حامله طائرات ذات حامل الطائرات اليوم
تعتمد اوكرانيا ما يسمى بالمنع او الاريا
ديل يعني ان يكون هناك منطقه عازله على
مدى الصواريخ التي تملكها لديها نبتون وهو
من صناعه روسيه صوفياتيه معدل من اوكرانيا
موجوده في اوديسا لديها صواريخ الهاربون
ولديها صواريخ مختلفه لديها المسيرات
المائيه السطحيه لديها المسيرات المائيه
تحت المياه ولديها المسيرات التي قد تصل
الى 800 كم الجويه هذه الوسائل هي وسائل
المنع هي مسائل منع ان تصل البحريه
الروسيه الى الاماكن والدليل على ذلك انه
بعد حادثات تلمسكوبا واسترداد جزيره
الافعى لم نجد على السواحل الاوكرانيه
عسكريه او قوارب او زوارق او بارجات قريبه
من البحر الشواطئ الاوكرانيه طيب الان
الرئيس زلينسكي يقول ان الهجوم المضاد كان
بوتيره ابطا مما كانوا يريدونه وبالتالي
هذا سمح للروس
بالاعداد
كخبير عسكري ماذا يمكنك ان تخبرنا عن ذلك
عثمان الاعداد هو الفتره الطويله التي
استغرقتها القوات الروسيه للدفاع وتحدثنا
عنها الكثير يعني على هذه المنصه في
الجزيره اليوم
الجبهه 900 كم
تعقيد الاعمال الاوكرانيه يعني ليس لدى
اوكرانيا القدره وموازين القوى لصالح
روسيه على سبيل المثال الحصر عثمان اليوم
في ليمان وكريمينا هناك ضغوطات عسكريه
كبيره جدا على القوات الاوكرانيه لماذا
لتثبيت هذه القوات ومنعها من القتال في
مكان اخر وبشكل ان تتشتت القوات
الاوكرانيه المعدله للهجوم من هنا القوات
الاوكرانيه لا تزال تجس النبض خاصه في
مخموت ولكنها تسعى الى ضرب الخلفيه في
الخلفيه الروسيه في القرن ومن هنا هذه
التفجيرات ومنها واهمها جسر قرش من بيروت
العميد الياس حنا شكرا جزيلا لك